-Thank you so much, New York.
Oh, my God,
I'm so happy to be back.
I've been traveling a lot
recently, which has been fun,
but it's weird, like, I've
noticed that my race changes
city to city?
[ Laughter ]
Like, when I'm in Chicago,
people just think that
I'm half black, half white.
When I'm in New York, people
think that I'm Puerto Rican?
[ Laughter ]
But when I'm in CVS,
everyone thinks I'm stealing.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which, you know,
it's really frustrating.
Um...because I am.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't want them
to catch me.
[ Laughter ]
But also, like, why do you think
that I'm stealing?
I look like I'm in a brochure
for a very expensive
liberal arts school? So...
[ Laughter ]
Mm. Leave me alone.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
ChapStick should be free.
My favorite articles right now
are all the articles of, like,
older people trying to come
to terms with the fact that
millennials are just poor.
[ Chuckles ]
Like the best one
I've seen is...
[ Haughty voice ] "why aren't
millennials buying diamonds?"
[ Laughter ]
"The industry is in peril."
And it's like one time I spent
more than $40 on groceries,
and my bank thought someone
stole my debit card.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Like, I would love --
I would love to get a chain,
but first I got to stop looking
at salmon
as a high-risk investment,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
There's levels to this.
Kind of feel like ever since
Trump won,
everything I do is radical
just because I'm a minority.
Like I wake up in the morning,
revolutionary.
[ Laughter ]
I ask the cashier for a cup
of water
but I low-key get some Sprite?
Anti-capitalist.
[ Laughter ]
But I feel like the election
has changed us although in ways
we're, like, just starting
to now realize.
'Cause the other day,
I was on the train,
and I see this, like,
mid-20s white dude,
like, very fit, athletic,
kind of fratty, professional,
just hit a crack pipe
and start freestyling?
[ Laughter ]
And, like, that's a level I'm
trying to get at, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Like, chasing all my dreams
at once, really.
[ Laughter ]
That's my goal. [ Chuckles ]
I can be kind of
an awkward flirt sometimes.
I can have a hard time flirting,
just because people don't always
read me as queer
when they first meet me
because I've been told that
I can come across as "masc,"
and if you don't know what that
means, it's basically just gay
for... [ Chuckles ]
"I'm not like other girls."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like a little weird, but I
actually really like whiskey.
So, I'm kind of quirky,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
I'm living in L.A. right now,
which is fun.
I miss New York so much,
but I found a way
to make L.A. fun in that
I'm just fully trying to hook up
with Uber drivers.
[ Laughter ]
And like, the other day, y'all,
like, I got so close.
Like I get in the car,
the guy's cute.
He's like, "Oh, where you
coming from?"
And I was like, "oh, a show."
And he's like, "oh, what
instrument do you play?"
And I was like, "the voice."
[ Laughs ]
But I was like, "no, I do
stand-up or whatever,"
and I say, "or whatever," so he
knows that I'm humble.
[ Laughter ]
And then he goes, "oh, my God,
like, I love stand-up."
"I've actually written a couple
jokes but I'm a little nervous
to get on stage and try it."
And I was like, "oh, my God, no,
you seem like you have such
a...natural stage presence."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "here, just tell me
a joke right now,
and we can work on it
in the car together."
And he was like, "are you sure?
I don't want to, like,
waste your time." I was like,
"no, just, like, go for it."
He was like...
[ Exhales deeply ] "okay, so,
uh... [ Inhales deeply ]
me and my girlfriend..."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "needs work.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
"Right here is fine. You can
just drop me off right now."
[ Laughter ]
But ultimately though, like,
I think the hardest part
about traveling is that you
really just start to lose track
of how hot you are
at a certain point
'cause like it's cliché
but it's true,
that, like, a Chicago hot is
a New York cute,
and a New York cute
is an L.A. shunned.
[ Laughter ]
Because, like, my brothers --
like, my, brothers are L.A.
They're both, like, tall, fit.
They carry themselves
with confidence.
I'm small, pale, I carry myself
like an inbred European Prince?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Like, I don't even really, like,
step when I walk.
I just sort of, like, glide
everywhere that I go. You know?
But I know I'm not ugly.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Thank you. Oh, thank you!
[ Applause ]
Like on a one to 10 scale,
I don't think that I could,
like, model,
but I could definitely
end a Republican Senator's
career. You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I feel like
I'm gonna like...
All right, thank you, guys.
You guys have been so much fun!
Thanks!